[Music]
hi there I'm Marisa and I'm Dave and we
work on the Google developer relations
team we're here at the deaf zone which
is the ecosystem for developers here at
Google cloud next right now at Deb's own
theater we're hosting a panel discussion
with the authors of go this is an
interactive session where people can
learn about the language and find out
what's coming next
come with us as we explore the rest of
the desktop let's go
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey come on
st. banana excellent perfect
we got one how's it look
I think it's looking pretty good
actually whoa I'm getting my snaps on
here at the network journey experiment
where we're showcasing the speed and
breadth of Google's worldwide network
what's going on here Carrie well exactly
so we're demonstrating here how Google's
investment in infrastructure allows our
customers to move their data around the
world without having to access the
public internet it it's fast and it's
secure and what is taking selfies tough
to do with you taking selfies so just
like when you travel and you get stamps
in your passport we're actually taking
the data that makes up your picture and
as it passes through these different
regions and these data centers we stamp
it with that location so when it comes
back around to the the destination we
took these pictures then we have actual
proof that your data moved through all
these data centers it's really cool as
my picture made it around the world yet
oh let's see
it did it has alright looking good none
the worse for wear thanks thank you
thanks so much for talking with me today
could you share a little bit what you
and your team are up to here in the DOM
so I'm from the developer relations
ecosystem team and we are informing
people here about the different
community problems that we have in the
area of cloud awesome so what type of
programs do you have that people can
take advantage of so you basically have
three programs so the Google developer
experts they ambassador in a specific
area of technology we have the Google
developer group so so local meetups that
you can go to all over the globe and we
also have the women techmakers that's a
program that increases diversity so
specifically there are programs that
people can take advantage of in
different communities all over the globe
yes you can basically everywhere you go
you can go to meetup you can meet with
Google developer experts and talk to
them about your area of interest awesome
thank you so much for your time thank
you it's 3:14 here in the dev zone and
that means it's pie time we're
celebrating because a fellow Googler of
mine Emma Haruka Yao recently broke the
Guinness world record for number of
digits of pi calculated using cloud
computing for the first time to compute
31.4 it's really in digits of pi that's
a lot of pie I'm gonna get my
celebration on
[Music]
hi there I'm here with Paris at one of
the community corners hey Paris has gone
it's going good are you buret I'm good
what do you do here I am a Google cloud
open-source strategist I work on
upstream kubernetes summit co-chair the
special interest group for contributor
experience and what makes kubernetes
unique the community definitely I think
we have one of the largest contributing
communities and I think it's important
to get customers to participate and not
and that's why I'm here today
awesome and what have you been doing
while you've been here at the tip zone
playing arcade game play it's been
wonderful like watching awesome speakers
and meeting awesome contributors it's
been great to have all this in one spot
[Music]
we showed you just a few cool
interactive experiences here at Google
cloud X but you don't have to be here in
person to check this out
you can visit all of these experiences
and more at GT o-- / showcase in
addition we're right in front of
hands-on lab you don't need to be here
to do that you can do it right now with
the claps get certified learn all about
Google products and get started today
and be sure to subscribe to the Google
cloud platform YouTube channel thank you
so much for joining us here at the death
house we really appreciate it
[Music]